so earlier today I was at this fast-food
joint called Five Guys which is like the
in and out of Texas and I was watching
these guys work there was six of them
working the right next to each other
touching each other the entire time 25
cars parked outside everybody wants
their food after I placed the order I
looked at him and I started seeing how
old is that guy he's probably 18
she's probably 19 he looks like he's 28
maybe he's the manager makes 15 bucks an
hour maybe those guys make minimum wage
720 Texas maybe 10 bucks an hour but at
least have a job very happy that we're
working customers still wanted something
to ordered they had to mask all 9-yard I
said man when are we gonna go back to
business as usual well I just a part I
want to hear your thoughts on this there
are two communities right now in America
well around the world but I'm talking
Maine you America there are those who
are afraid of coronavirus what do we do
we have some numbers 30-some thousand
it's a real number we have cases one
percent of America has been tested
doesn't look like they're moving too
quickly
that's ouchy not CDC not World Health
Organization you're not seeing what's
gonna happen their vaccine I don't know
medication don't know there's a lot of
uncertainty people are worried then you
got the other side which is people who
have small businesses and they're
calling me left and right
obviously I advise many of them but
they're calling me small business owners
are not billionaires these are not
people that you know have 300 million
dollars sitting in their bank account
these are not those guys these are
people that run businesses they employ
65% of America and they don't have a lot
of cash reserves
these are restaurant owners this is your
favorite restaurant you go to you know
the Greek restaurant that's only one of
them but you love the place you go there
Friday night that's the small business
owner he or she doesn't know if they're
gonna make it or not that store you go
to buy clothes you know the one that no
one thinks about but you like to go to
it cuz you like the owner
it's 34 employees there they all treat
you good you go there
small business owner
I understand both parties those who are
afraid on the coronavirus side because
let's just say they lost somebody thirty
something thousand people have died in
America there's 330 million people
that's point zero zero I believe one
percent who has experience losing
somebody to coronavirus I get many calls
I'm in the insurance industry when
you're in the life insurance industry
you get that one call you don't want to
get which is what such-and-such passed
away and I got 14,000 agents many times
their family members relatives fathers
mothers spouse all of them I've been to
funerals very emotional for me because I
love these people not watching when I
see their pain I fully understand it I
fully understand it but I also
understand the pain of a founder let me
tell what I mean by a pain of a founder
a founder is somebody that quit their
job maybe when I started a company and
they put all their money on the line
it's very hard on the husband the wife
the kids the family because many times
the founder is not working forty hours
not 60 hours not 80 hours if you're a
founder that you run a company with 50
plus employees you are non-stop for
several years until you can afford to
maybe take a breather but you're still
not free you still working your butt off
I saw an ad or you're saying the fact
that major retailers in America are
going out of business these are
Nordstrom's I go to Nordstrom's I won
Nordstrom sustain business JCPenney
Macy's I grew up to JC Penney and Macy's
wonder but how many business books that
we read about JC Penney these are
somebody's name Neiman Marcus
Nordstrom's Macy's JC Penney these are
going out of business there was a
founder who started this company there
were co-founders there were original 15
employees five employees a hundred
employees that are proud to say I'm
employee number 38 I'm employee number
22 they're proud they say those stories
to their kids their grandkids all those
years of putting into making the
business survive they're on the verge of
filing bankruptcy AMC I go to AMC
Theatres regularly when I was broke had
nothing to my name as a
ten year old kid I would go recycle cans
to have money to go to the theater and
watch a movie it's a form of
entertainment and later on as a civil
zigzag kid if in my 20s sometimes when I
had a bad month or bad week my system
knew if I came back from lunch would
popcorn all over my shrivel my tie on
it's because I want to watch the movie
with a bunch of 80 year old senior
citizens at 10 o'clock matinee by myself
cuz it was a form of therapy therapy MCS
about to go out of business four point
nine billion dollars in debt it's a
company that was started 100 years ago a
hundred years ago I believe it's January
1st of 1920 maybe I'm off think they've
been on for about a hundred years I got
a thousand different locations eleven
thousand screens nearly forty thousand
employees AMC is filing bankruptcy
AMC's not their market is not to rich
people
its mineral America low income it's a
form of entertainment I go take my kids
to the movies how many times have you
done that how many times have I done
that how many times do we do bad
many of us went on a date with our wives
or husbands - first time at AMC I mean
somebody started that company with an
idea of wanted to entertain millions of
people millions of people and shutting
down the economy for four weeks get home
it's gonna put a lot of these guys out
of business and even when we were what
women go to back to business as usual
think about the first time you're on a
flight and somebody coughs and they
don't cover their mouth cover your mouth
when you sneeze or you cough don't tell
me what to do I agree with them don't
get involved then if I bring something
and if we keep it the way it is right
now how much longer can we go like this
we're keeping the economy shut down how
many more restaurant owners do they need
to go out of business go to the residual
effects of it ready here we go
restaurant owner goes out of business
who do you think is gonna fight with the
most when he comes home spouse hmm one
day fight how long do you think people
can handle finances financial issues
what does it lead to divorce the worst
attorneys are about to blow up with
business the next three to six months
this is not funny kids are gonna pay the
price for this so now more kids going
through a divorce families divorce is
gonna go up in the next six twelve
months we'll be looking back on some of
the stats if we go the way we are
residual effects money's not there kids
are not going to private school kids are
now - family's confused they don't know
what to do why
so look I'm not telling you have the
answers all I'm telling you is I
understand people who are worried I
understand it and I understand people
who are small business owners who have
put everything into their small business
not to become rich and wealthy and brag
about their wealth why do people do what
they do you know men are driven by
making their women proud they want to
lay next to their wives and their wives
to say it's my husband and men want to
hear that and women want to be able to
have a husband or man say she's got my
back best thing that ever happened to me
love and respect it's not original
concept it's been around for a while and
kids would like to see an example that's
safe peaceful fun filled with love these
are innocent kids man you know
we got to figure out a way to get this
thing going by the way keep this in mind
this is coming from a guy that we had
our best month ever in a month of March
our numbers are incredible I'm not
sharing this with you because of what's
happening to me I'm sharing this with
you because I have a channel with a few
million subscribers were entrepreneurs
from Durant from around the world
message me for counsel about what to do
with their businesses and I hear them
out and I hear their voice and their
fears and I understand them and there
are many ways to solve this but I want
to hear from you I don't want to tell
you my ideas I actually want to hear it
from you and I want to actually read all
your comments so one are you comfortable
with the economy opening back up
businesses if your answer is yes how
would you go about doing it how would
you do it
who would you allow to stay home how
would you handle if somebody's working
at the office and you got a hundred
employees at the company work at 200
employees 300 employees and somebody
comes in and says someone in my family
or someone in this place has coronavirus
do you all of a sudden send everybody
home for two weeks or do you just say we
don't know what we're gonna be doing
these are all answers questions that we
have to have answers for and I'd love to
start a dialogue with you leading it so
again one what are your thoughts about
reopening up the economy some states are
doing it at different measures but they
are and two if we do how would you do it
what would you do with the people that
you're not comfortable to be able to
work environment and what kind of
protocols would you do to make sure that
moving forward people have to know
coronavirus gonna be part of our lives
what do we want to do about it I want to
hear your thoughts please comment below
on your thoughts regarding these
questions thank you